[Music]
[Applause]
Hall of Famer and two-time champ with
the Knicks is the former Senator Bill
Bradley joining us on the show Bill good
to talk to you again uh the passing of
Willis Reed at the age of 80. what's
your favorite story of Willis Reed that
you can tell this audience
uh rookie and uh Willis of course is the
captain
and he only calls me by my last name
and that bothered me called everybody
else by their first name so I went to
him and I said Willis how about call me
by my uh first name like you call
everybody else and he pauses 69 240 he
looks stand at me it says okay
Bradley
in other words he was letting me know
who the boss was take us back to 1970
game seven when did you guys realize
that Willis was going to play in that
this sighting game against the Lakers
well the butcher says he knows that he
was going to take a shot I I didn't so I
didn't know he was going to play until
he showed up on the court
and uh you know I'm warming up and the
Lakers are warming up and suddenly
there's a rumble and the crowd the
building begins to shake and I look out
as well is coming on in West Baylor and
Chamberlain have stopped their
practicing and they're watching to see
Willis walk on the floor they want to
see if he can move at all because he's
torn the abductor muscle you can't lift
your legs supposedly and um then we get
the the game Begins the first two times
down as it has it will stays under the
basket and doesn't come out Willis has
an open 16-foot shot it hits both of
them after that the game's over I mean
Klein has one of the great I think the
best seventh game in the history of the
NBA he scores like 36 points 19 assists
I remember I introduced him one day and
I said in Clyde treasury scored 36
points 19 assists and he says and and
nine rebounds Annie wasn't the MVP
yeah that they gave it to Willis I think
that the the MVP goes to the man with
the courage and the total uh put his his
career on the line for his team that
doesn't happen often in sports but it
happened that day in that circumstance
did you guys design plays did Red
Holtzman design plays for Willis the
first two times down against Wilt
Chamberlain no it was just the fact that
if we'll if uh will it come out it would
have been a contested shot but you know
we'll didn't really come out
can you can you describe what it was
like to play against Wilt Chamberlain
uh well he was a incredibly imposing uh
physical uh specimen I mean yeah i i as
a forward would often reach back and try
to knock the ball out of the hand of the
center right so when I reached back to
trying to walk knock it out wilt's hand
it was like hitting a brick wall at one
point I even injured my shoulder trying
to do it
but he was uh you know he was a uh he
was a tremendous player but in you know
in my mind I picked Russell over
Chamberlain that's the old that's the
old uh contest but you know we'll seem
to think that the answer to everything
was a stat
and uh I don't think that's what
basketball is all about
what was it like to play against Russell
who's the smartest player ever played
against
he uh
got the best out of his teammates
they turned defense into offense
and he was uh you know somebody who
really knew what was going through the
mind of a player for example once were I
hit uh like three in a row on Sat
Sanders who's guarding me we get to a
foul and Russell's on one side of the
foul line I'm on the other and satch is
next to me he looks at satch and he
looks at me and he says come on sash you
can let that guy do it
I thought about that for a while
Russell Russ is getting into your head
but he wanted me to do no no respect uh
you're Princeton tigers in the sweet 16.
um first of all take us back was it the
third place was it a consolation game
when you scored 58
uh yeah that was the third place game
what do you remember about that
um I remember that my teammates and my
coach said shoot the damn ball why
was my last game
and they knew that I passed it a lot you
know passed to them and so forth and
they said shoot it and so I did and uh
didn't have a bad night
[Laughter]
but it's a third place game so
anymore
uh what I thought about of course was
that we lost the night the night before
which is what uh I'd want to be playing
in the finals not in the consolation
this Princeton tiger team competing in
you know what is the landscape of
college basketball with nil and you know
Big Time money here
uh how surprised are you Princeton is
here in the sweet 16 given what college
basketball is now
uh uh I'm very pleased it shows that the
dedication to the craft is paying off in
other words they know the fundamentals
and they play unselfishly they box out
they hit the open shot
they play good defense
um and I'm glad to see Mitch has got
them at a point where they believe in
themselves and it couldn't be coming at
a better time because Creighton won't be
easy no no further game will be easy not
to the Past worries either the the they
Rose to the occasion they showed real
character in my view when you were
Senator did you have basketball games
that you guys would play like
congressmen Senators any of them they
had a gym in the house not in the Senate
and I I went over to play basketball I
think three times in 18 years and each
of the times was because I wanted
somebody's vote that I knew
okay did you let him beat you to get
their vote no no no no no no
I I don't I don't remember what happened
I have no recollection yeah I'll bet
I'll bet when you got to the NBA did you
guys have to buy your own shoes
yeah I'm
on shoes I sent them to St Louis
Missouri to my mother's college roommate
who's a chiropodist who put big arches
in them I bought Converse All-Stars sent
to St Louis with the big arches in
return to me yeah
why didn't guys get sprained ankles back
then bill
wearing the converse All-Stars well some
people did get sprained ankles but uh I
mean the converse All-Stars weren't
terrible shoes at all
yeah but they didn't have any support
there I wore those high top Converse
was that why you didn't make it into
three yeah I didn't make it in college
bill
I had a better chance of being a senator
I think than uh yeah right I've been
playing playing college basketball uh
what do you think about your Knicks
today
I like the way they're playing
I mean I hope that they uh you know make
it in to the playoffs and go have a
great playoffs
do you have any memorabilia left from uh
your next days winning the Championships
you keep oh yeah yeah I got
what are you going
um rings
although I don't I I misplaced one of my
championship rings
I can't find it but that's just the only
testimony to my own messiness not to is
it in the house somewhere though yeah I
would I would assume it is yeah I got it
you know we have to have an
investigation here and get well you
don't seem too by the way I I have about
27 parents of my old Converse if you're
interested I would love to have a pair
could I put a pear in the man cave Yeah
by all means okay uh as long as you
autograph them
okay all right we're gonna I'll put you
on hold can we do that I'll get I'll
give you the address can I do that yeah
let me before you
I have a 73 73 Championship right there
was that more special than 70
uh well somebody was the Mountaintop 73
was I had more fun playing that year
than any year that I played basketball
uh the team was great Earl arrives Jerry
Lucas arrived Willis was still there
Barnett still had some uh moves uh so
that was to me the most enjoyable year
70 was a championship it was great but
uh you know there were a lot of
attention he hadn't been there before
but now we knew what it was and we knew
how we could get there and uh we went
out and did it more interesting to watch
Earl The Pearl Monroe or or Clyde
they're different players and they bring
different things to the game uh Earl's
virtuosity was improvisation and Clyde's
strength was fundamental basketball with
great quickness with his hands and
particularly on Steals and a willingness
to uh he played at a pace that seemed
slightly slow but wasn't you know it was
like Oscar Robertson played at a pace
that he he paced it the way he wanted to
Pace it and he got the shot he wanted
which was really important yeah Kawhi
Leonard does that Luka doncic they they
almost slow the game to the PACE that
they want to play it's like everybody
else is playing uh you know rock and
roll and they're playing jazz out there
to a certain extent that's true
but a lot of times we did this without
the ball with without the player having
the ball the ball is moving
it wasn't me holding the ball but the
ball was going from one player to
another and but we weren't rushing to
pass
how good a player was Phil Jackson
that was a good player he was uh you
know he was on our 73 championship team
he was the backup forward and uh he had
a great hook shot
and he was a competitor people say well
did you see Phil Jackson's uh
coaching future yeah where the answer is
yes it was uh you know it stood into the
game unselfish uh studied opponents and
his teammates was dedicated to uh
defense which means positioning and I
could easily see how he would have would
become a great coach when's the last
time you shot a basketball
oh God it's about uh
before the pandemic okay like uh 2019.
don't you miss that feeling just taking
a couple of jumpers and just here here
in the net I um jumpers I don't know
about it said shot yeah
I miss it and you know I sometimes uh at
least until the pandemic I would go down
and alone in a court and just shoot and
I'd go through the usual routine I no
longer hit 15 in a row from five spots
but I'd say if I hit you know 10 out of
13 I'd be satisfied at 15 feet
yeah I love doing it I love solo I like
just going out there's something about
just sort of going into a vacuum and
just shooting hoops and letting
everything else fall to the Wayside
that's very true there's a there's a
rhythm to the bouncing of the ball the
movement of the arms the follow through
and then when you are rewarded with that
magic sound
squish I know no better sound no except
for a golf ball going in the hole that
one's up there too but I I wouldn't know
about that
uh thanks again I know uh obviously
mixed emotions here with Princeton and
Willis but uh it's great it's mixed
emotions uh
I uh
I marked yesterday morning I got a call
from Gail Willis's wife
and when she told me he had passed
you know I sat down on a rock and cried
literally
and um
it was a man of great dignity and
strength and
tremendous friend to me for many years
I'll miss him
you rarely heard a bad word about him
I mean and even if you did unless your
name was Rudy Larusso oh
that former San Francisco Warrior yeah
that's the guy he knocked out
but Rudy probably had it coming to him
bill I don't know I don't know knowing
bill you know knowing Rudy I mean he was
an instigator though wasn't he well I
went to Dartmouth what do you expect
he couldn't get into Princeton right
I don't know yeah uh thanks again for
joining us and I look forward to getting
a pair of those Converse
thank you Bill that's uh the former
Senator Bill bradding Hall of Famer won
a couple of championships with the
Knicks
you go back uh Player of the Year 1965
LED Princeton to the final four it was a
very good NBA player